[Musica]
[Risate]
buongiorno a tutti oggi sono qui per
aiutarvi di un cambia un po insolito
quello che devi the incarcerato dal fine
della pena e per fare quello parlerò del
progetto di chiusi cos'è il progetto
primi chiusi non è altro che insegnare
la boxe in carcere io so già la faccia
che fra le teche questo pazzo invece
funziona però per andare avanti nel
racconto sono costretto a fare un salto
indietro un salto di vent'anni
io da giovane ho sempre rubato o sempre
rubato non perché avessi veramente
bisogno di soldi ma perché fanno mi
riconosceva un ruolo sociale all'interno
del quartiere provengo
un testo un po difficile di un quartiere
periferico di grano e quindi ho sempre
cercato nel furto quella che è la
capacità di realizzazione tante che
oppure quindi ho continuato a farlo
perché mi piaceva la tristezza quella
che è la vita nel furto e sono arrivati
per parecchio tempo
ho sempre rubato scooter moto macchine
finché un giorno accade qualcosa passa a
prendermi un mio amico con lo scooter
una sorta di collega e si esce per
rubare incontriamo dalle parti di robbie
è una periferia di milano
questo ragazzo sullo scooter io scendo
dall'altra ma tutti era un pugno in
faccia al ragazzo con il motorino e
portò via il suo sud scale nella fuga
incrociamo una pattuglia dei carabinieri
ci fermano in amico collega ovviamente
scappa
io vengo portato in caserma in caserma
venga interrogato per circa due ore
ovviamente cercavano di farsi dire il
nome del mio complice del mio collega
fortunatamente sono riuscito a resistere
alle
insistenze degli agenti però ovviamente
c'era quella che l'accusa di rapina
rapina aggravata dal pugno quindi devo
[Musica]
ammanettato ed eco portato al carcere di
san vittore nel carcere san vittore
vengo perquisito il dopo la
perquisizione gli viene chiesto di
togliere la cifra dei pantaloni e quelli
che sono i vari lacci per le scarpe
io non capivo questa richiesta che ho
chiesto delle spiegazioni alle guardie
carcerarie e mi hanno risposto che è
solito come prassi per chi viene
arrestato la prima proprietà togliere
tutto ciò che può aiutare il tentativo
di suicidio
io già lì avvertivo una sorta di
repulsione per un ambiente che poteva
solo concepire il fatto che per uno
sbaglio in passato ha detto ieri la vita
questo accade accade spesso non sono in
carcere anche fuori e quindi vengo
condotto nella mia cella c'è la 309 in
cui passò due giorni e tre notti dopo
scarcerato perché a giudice non
convalida d'arresto
vengo scarcerato appena metto il piede
fuori dal carcere
sono libero sono libero e qua parte
il mio primo vero cantante e cioè il
confronto con mio padre è un countdown
che è fatto di metri quindi arrivo a
casa parlo con mio padre mi confronto
con lui c'è un confronto verbale che mi
aiuta ad avere delle certezze su già
quello che pensavo che comunque il
percorso criminale che poi è fatto di
carcere non era quello che volevo per la
mia vita quindi il giorno dopo
io sono dio criminale però accade che
questo arresto e comunque il fatto che
io non abbia parlato con le guardie mi
fa avere una sorta di promozione sul
campo per quanto è quella che fa parte
della forma mentis dell'ambiente di
strada ma io scelgo di non cogliere
questo vantaggio
e allora scelgo un modo per tenermi
occupato ho pensato vabbè
cerco di scrivere anzi mi vadano ad
iscrivere in una palestra di pugilato
così parto con il corso mi alleno più
volte alla settimana e che cosa
accade che dentro di me sento che le
abilità che avevo le foto quindi la
destrezza il colpo d'occhio vengono
sostituite dalla destrezza e dal colpo
d'occhio di riuscire a colpire qualcun
altro poi un altro veramente non vuole
collaborare con me ok quindi scelgo di
seguire quella strada e è per questo che
oggi sono qui davanti a voi a parlare
con voi con 104 n 104 match ma c'è un
particolare fondamentale da sottolineare
io sono qui fisicamente davanti a cui
oggi perché sono stato di tutto utile
ieri la capacità del pugile è quella di
affrontare le sue paure come quella di
parlare con voi non è non è semplice
eppure lo faccio affronta la paura e ne
va mi avvio c'è c'è scritto tu gilet in
realtà non è corretto io sono un ex
pugile non smesso di combattere nel 2015
ma io
non sono un pugile sono tante cose sono
un operaio sono un padre di famiglia un
compagno di vita un amico sono tante
cose ma la scritta pugile che c'era
sopra è la rappresentazione di me nella
società
è questo il concetto che cerchiate c è
portare all'interno del carcere di la
bolla
ovviamente non è semplice non è semplice
ma abbiamo degli alleati sono due
elementi che accomunano il pugile con il
detenuto
il primo è il tempo questo canale che
ovviamente il detenuto possiede e è un
lettore di giovani un giorno che passa
sempre un giorni meno verso quella
chiedere che chi è la libertà ma anche
fucile a canna su un incontro di dieci
riprese ogni ramp che passa è sempre un
grande in nero verso la fine ma
soprattutto quello che li accomuna è la
capacità di restare
cosa fa il pugile quando combatte
non so se voi avete mai visto un match
di pugilato però nell'atto dello scambio
tecnico c'è sempre un pugile che
palesemente in difficoltà che magari è
ferito magari soffre proprio in
quell'istante il pugile potrebbe
sottrarsi dal dolore come al sembrano in
campo il paradenti voltandosi di fronte
all'avversario
ok potrebbe abbandonare invece no
sceglie di restare sta nella difficoltà
il detenuto allo stesso modo
sceglie di restare nella pena non è
scontata te lo faccio
purtroppo lui ha solo due moni poi
cercare la fuga o può togliersi la vita
ma invece sceglie di restare e
il concetto che che vogliamo portare
all'interno del carcere è esattamente
questo a restare in carcere e scontare
la pena è un vantaggio che devono
sfruttare cosa accade però accade che
spesso il detenuto passa in carcere
molto tempo amici a 12 anni 15 anni e
c'è un
in particolare una caratteristica che ci
accomuna tutti è la capacità di
adattarsi e di abituarsi
il carcerato si abitua a cosa però si
abitua a scarseggia la compagnia di un
amico si abitua a stare senza la birra
si abitua a stare si rifà al mare ad
andare al mare alla compagnia del
proprio figlio della compagna e ad un
certo punto si rende conto che può
vivere lo stesso senza quelle cose e in
questo istante nella consapevolezza che
avviene la trasformazione sbagliata da
bitetto forniamo il carcerato la società
nostra non si può permettere dei
carcerati per che cosa si perché fra
dieci anni quella persona poi il
carcerato uscirà dal carcere e sarà tra
noi sarà con i nostri figli
sarà a contatto con i nostri parenti con
i familiari con le persone care e la
società
non si può permettere un carcerato tra
le scale
molti pensano che il concetto di
riabilitazione anche se è una parola a
noi non piace mai quella che più
rappresenta il percorso
molti pensano che la riabilitazione sia
per il detenuto ma è sbagliato la
riabilitazione è prima per noi per noi
come persone e quello che cerchiamo è
appunto attraverso la boxe di
trasformare il detenuto in pugi in modo
da dargli un'altra rappresentazione di
sé non solo con se stesso ma per altri
attualmente al corso e ci sono 41
persone iscritte è il miglior corso che
abbia mai avuto e comprende ovviamente
persone di tutto il mondo qualsiasi
paese fa parte del carcere non è
semplice ci sono delle difficoltà
correlate alla razza alla religione alla
differenza di reato che non è scontato
però sotto quello che l'ombrello dello
sport della boxe si convive e gli
obiettivi per il 2019 sono quelli di
organizzare un evento di pugilato
all'interno del carcere di bollate dove
sette pugili carcerati combattono con
sette pugili fuori sembra che che le
istituzioni ci aiutino anche in questo
ma vi ho parlato finora del mio passato
di quello che conosco nel carcere di
quello che so della voce ma vorrei dirvi
cosa porto io fuori dal carcere sono lì
da domani la sg 2 anni e credo di avere
acquisito seriamente
cosa si racchiude nella parola libertà
viene normale pensare che alla parola
sia collegato un gesto fisico quindi non
poter fare qualcosa non poter andare a
bere la birra questo è anche vero ma
conoscendo i detenuti conoscendole le
problematiche che hanno perché quella
che la boxe ha un vantaggio rispetto a
tutti gli altri sport che attraverso il
contatto fisico si trascende quella che
era vicina si crea una sorta di dignità
sportiva per cui è più facile parlarsi
dopo che ci sia i piedi e quindi sono
venuto a conoscenza che presidio un
detenuto non può scegliere dall'oggi al
domani di andare a trovare un parente
chi è ricoverato in ospedale non può
farlo non può andare al funerale di un
parente di una madre non può farlo deve
fare richiesta e non è detto che va
accettato soprattutto non per tempo
quindi secondo me il concetto di libertà
è strettamente legato alle cose
perché per lui sono davvero normalissime
di andare a un matrimonio di un amico a
un funerale di un amico
questo secondo me è il vero concetto di
libertà
oggi è di 22 di settembre e fra
esattamente un mese canti proprio la
ripresa della notte di spiegano buchi
stefano cucchi ha cercato un percorso
alternativo alla strada con la borsa
ovviamente stefano è una persona che ha
sbagliato e il suo percorso è stato
interrotto da persone che hanno
sbagliato la grande caratteristica che
penso ci accomuni tutti è la capacità di
sbagliare
[Musica]
che
gravissimo
mirko chiari